[Music]
and tonight more developments in the
nefarious dealings of the biden family
corrupt business bureau in other words
the biden corrupt syndicate because
there are new reports that hunter biden
remains financially tied to that chinese
equity firm that invested in a
technology company sanctioned in 2019
for committing human rights violations
against uyghur
muslims and of course now we still have
more questions than answers surrounding
zero experience hunter and the shading
art dealings like what exactly is the
marketplace for that crappy drawing that
i see on on tv right now why all the
secrecy oh people can bid anonymously
okay and get this one of the guests at
hunter's recent art shows in la that
would be mayor eric garcetti who was
recently nominated by biden to be the
ambassador to india now circle back gen
sake is asked about hunter's dealings
you know sort of like portraits of a
crack addict but she refused to give a
straight answer take a look there was
concern when president biden took office
about his son's business dealings with
china he was supposed to divest himself
of his stake in a
chinese private equity firm in december
with ties to the chinese central bank as
of april he had not yet done that and at
some point you were going to get back to
us on that do you have an update on that
has he dissolved that interest now
i'd point you to his representatives on
that he doesn't work in the
administration you should talk to his
representatives that remains his policy
he's been working to wind that down
beyond that if they would talk to his
representatives how about is joe
compromised could hunter made money
without any experience with china a
russian oligarch kazakhstan oligarch and
then of course barisma holdings oh and
the libyan government did not have a
very favorable opinion about hunter
biden and his private life his drug use
and well use of prostitutes anyway we
did reach out to hunter biden for a
comment
shockingly has yet to get back to us
here for reaction fox news contributor
jason chaffetz along with author of do
what you said you would do ohio
congressman jim jordan by the way if
republicans would do that you know
donald trump gave the republican party a
spine a backbone to fight for the things
they say that they're going to fight for
some of them i see especially in the
senate raising the debt ceiling they may
be losing that that stiffer spine that
trump gave him
i want to talk about this
if i'm the son of a vice president and
the vice president of the united states
leverages a billion dollars to get a
prosecutor fired because they're
investigating your son if your last
name's trump jim jordan what happens if
your last name is trump and you're
getting money from kazakhstan china and
russia what's the difference in the
coverage and what's the difference from
the democratic party yeah you're don
junior and you got you got business ties
with china you got some new found art
talent you got anonymous sales to people
and let's say uh newt gingrich's wife
callesta gingrich is up for nomination
to be ambassador to the vatican you
don't think that's a story for goodness
sake so but no no what's the justice
department looking into right now not
hunter buying in his china business ties
and other ties with you know
questionable people or these art sales
what is the justice department looking
into parents
parents who objected school board
meetings to critical race theory are now
going to be defined as domestic
terrorists with the latest memo that
just a attorney general garland sends
out this is what just ticks off
americans so much sean and it's
ridiculous jason i'm not trying to be
insulting to the guy's artwork he's not
a real artist i mean
with all due respect i mean even the
libyans said yeah he's a crack addict
what is his portraits of a crack addict
paint by numbers and you're going to get
up to 500 grand for one of these
paintings i don't think anybody in their
right mind would pay 500 000 for this
crap
well it looks like a blood clot that
somehow got captured on a piece of paper
and look
joe biden himself brought as the vice
president brought hunter biden to china
on air force two he brought him on air
force two to uh mexico and and he has
ties
to china too
he went on that train
ten days later he's making the money
with the bank of china yeah
that's right and so joe biden as the
candidate joe biden as the
president-elect joe biden is the
president said none of his family would
have any relationships no investments in
any foreign entities but the chinese
filings that took place just two weeks
ago show that hunter biden has divested
none of his investment which some are
estimating is up to work worth up to 20
million dollars based on a 400 000 or so
investment in 2017. and so this is a
very legitimate thing because the
president keeps lying to us it is
relevant to the oversight committee it
is relevant to congress it is relevant
to the white house and the american
people all right let me take it a step
the united states of america jim jordan
i'm watching these planes of of china uh
their their saber rattling over taiwan
yeah i see that vladimir putin gets a
waiver for his pipeline while firing
american keystone exile pipeline workers
and
and eliminating high-paying career jobs
uh as i look at those two instances and
can you connect the dots
the the first lady of moscow three and a
half million to hunter biden uh 1.5
billion dollar deal bank of china 100
000
shopping spree is why isn't anyone
asking the question are the bidens
compromised by russia by china
kazakhstan and by ukraine because it
seems to me no it's it might be yeah no
i think it's twofold i think that's a
real question it should be investigated
but in today's world when you're on this
march towards communism as the left is
you don't do the real investigations
that need to be done plus also when you
project weakness sean from the oval
office which is we know exactly what joe
biden's doing bad people could become
emboldened and do bad things we saw that
with the whole debacle that was the
withdrawal from afghanistan so those two
things coupled together i think is why i
am so nervous and so many people are so
nervous about how we look around the
world and what may happen to as you say
uh taiwan or one of the former russian
satellite countries that that are now
independent so i think that is very
concerning but this is what happens when
you have when you have fauci say that oh
you do it for the greater good forget
your freedom when you have a attorney
general investigate parents who he calls
domestic terrorists because they go to a
school board meeting objectives critical
race during be taught and then when you
have something like what happened to
senator cinema with the left that is
what it looks like when you have the
left on this rapid march towards
socialism thank you jim jordan thank you
jason chaffetz hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else